we've talked before about how during the
Obama administration Republicans
insisted in baseless conspiracy theories
relating to President Obama about Obama
planning to or wanting to or scheming to
stay in power longer than two
presidential terms sometimes it would be
Obama is going to declare martial law to
justify suspending the 2016 election
sometimes it was Obama is going to
change the Constitution so that
presidents can have three terms or
unlimited terms or whatever and anyone
who had a good head on their shoulders
realized that from day one it was
absolutely ridiculous and completely not
based in fact but there were lots of
Republicans that fell for that
conspiracy just like they fell for the
Trump fomented birther conspiracy theory
so this unfortunately was a topic of
discussion among certain enclaves of the
right while Barack Obama was president
Obama will not relinquish power he will
do everything under the under the Sun
possible to try to stay in power beyond
2016 of course it never happened and
that was completely predictable Donald
Trump on the other hand has actually
signaled that he at least has
aspirations to more than two
presidential terms and Donald Trump also
has serious authoritarian tendencies and
I'm not going to rehash the full list of
examples here but lately Donald Trump
keeps quote joking about serving more
than two presidential terms and to be
clear I've said it before I don't think
Donald Trump would get away with it if
he tried but Donald Trump continues to
reference this idea of staying in power
for more than eight years and over the
weekend Trump sort of again alluded to
this on Twitter take a look saying quote
a poll should be done on which is the
more dishonest and deceitful newspaper
the failing New York Times or the Amazon
lobbyist Washington Post they are both
the disgrace to our country the enemy of
the people
but I just can't seem to figure out
which is worse
the good news is that at the end of six
years after America has been made great
again and I leave the beautiful White
House do you think the people would
demand that I stay longer Keep America
great
both of these horrible papers will click
quickly go out of business
and be forever gone so by itself this is
like nothing it's just another dumb
tweet from the president sort of
alluding to staying longer than eight
years in the White House but remember
the context remember what Donald Trump
said before the 2016 election he said he
might not accept the results of the 2016
election if they said that Hillary
Clinton had won and by the way he hasn't
accepted the popular vote results yes he
did win electoral II he lost the popular
vote badly by more than any recent
president has lost the popular vote and
he doesn't accept that he has insisted
that three to five million people voted
illegally for Hillary Clinton
remember when Donald Trump said last
year behind closed doors to Republican
donors that he likes what the Chinese
president has done saying quote he's now
president for life president for life no
he's great and look he was able to do
that I think it's great maybe we'll have
to give it a shot someday
once again the tendency the appeal to
Donald Trump of the presidency possibly
for him lasting longer than eight years
so as Chrissy Lazzaro in a recent CNN
op-ed I do not think that Donald Trump
is going to try to change the
constitution to stay in power beyond two
terms if he wins re-election let's not
do what Republicans did under Barack
Obama and go crazy with all of these
absurd conspiracy theories I do believe
that Donald Trump is likely to question
the 20/20 results if he loses and to at
least try to make the case that he was
not fairly defeated and he's already
started to lay the groundwork for that
and I do expect Donald Trump to dance
around with the idea if he wins
reelection in 2020 that maybe he should
remain in power beyond that but I don't
think that it's going to succeed and I
don't think that there's going to be any
serious case that Trump makes that would
actually challenge the sort of framework
which limits presidents to eight years
Trump yes is a major authoritarian Trump
yes must get what he wants yes Trump is
the epitome of the sort of entitled rich
kid but is he going to actually try to
forcefully stay in power
I believe the answer is no and even if
he does there is no way that he could
pull it off even if he actually tries to
do that the point is if you were one of
the people before 2016 saying that
Barack Obama is going to try to stay in
power how can you not be saying the same
thing about Donald Trump because Donald
Trump has actually shown us that behind
the curtain he likes the idea of more
than eight years as president and he is
more than willing to question the
validity and trustworthiness of election
results when the results simply don't
suit him as that entitled rich kid that
he has been his entire life all I'm
saying is there's a double standard
there I don't believe that this is a
real risk that Donald Trump is going to
try to carry out